okay everybody this is my spoiler review
of men if you haven't seen the film go
check out my spoiler free review first
and then come back to this after you've
seen the film unless you want spoilers
be my guest this was directed by alex
garland and written by alex garland and
it's an a24 production i myself have a
love hate relationship with alex
garland's work i am a huge fan of ex
machina and i was so so about
annihilation and so so about the show
devs he did so my expectations were
hoping that this would just at least be
pretty good and i was not vibe in this
film at all and you see from the first
flashback in this film
you can tell from that first scene
everything that happened from her bloody
nose that she was abused that he was
jumping off the building that
this story that you need to know that
you see multiple scenes of between her
and her husband you could have got from
one scene so that frustrated me i felt
like as the movie went on the flashback
scenes weren't adding anything so that
was a big problem i had and then
once you start figuring out what goes on
right with rory kinnear's character in
jeffrey it just felt silly to me and i'm
down with you know
having someone play different versions
of themselves but
when you have it that you have this like
silly cgi version of him as a kid that
just did not look great to me that it
made me just
takes me out of it and then
i don't know about you if i miss it when
i went to the bathroom like twice during
it but how did she not even address that
the guy had the same face was the same
guy like it made sense when she saw the
naked version of him because it's from a
distance he looks so different but when
she's in the bar why isn't there
acknowledgement of her knowing like
you're the same guy or saying anything
like that it was such a glaring plot
hole to me i could not get it out of my
head so i just couldn't believe that it
was just acting like this wasn't a thing
like how can my main character not even
address that they all look like the same
guy it was like you're trying to tell me
that she doesn't realize this is the
same face until
way way later so that was absurd to me
is this really like art when you're
getting all this body horror at the end
and he's birthing
multiple versions of himself it becomes
the husband and we get this moment where
she cuts his hand it was just felt like
i said this in my sport for review but
like i haven't felt that angry and not
enjoying something since
jordan peel's twilight zone reboot and
that i say because it's like
to me comes off silly
not as smart as it thinks it is and it's
pandering because it's so on the nose
about the message and not really selling
you in the message and something that
feels fresh or something that's really
showing you on things that serve this
story purpose it's a lot of like how
many ways can we make rory kinnear be
different and do these do different
facets of men but
where it didn't feel
right was how redundant it was and how i
just wasn't buying the whole situation
and how they really didn't make her
character smart and that she's not right
away getting
what's happening it was so bizarre to me
like it wasn't working it wasn't
bringing me in and making me immersed
into it so i think what i liked the most
was actually the beginning i liked the
feeling of aloneness she had that we
were with her we had these beautiful
shots but then it was like oh this is
more alex garland when he's doing
annihilations ending where you're seeing
this figure and you're getting all this
creepy choir music the whole movie and
holding on a lot of long shots with
different imagery right but it's just
over and over this trick he does and
going into these little flashbacks that
you already knew it was going on from
the first flashback so
that to me isn't good storytelling and
it's disappointing and
i'm just like was this even a fully
fleshed out story and is this just to
the point of like do they even know
what's going on alex garland when he's
making this or is he just having fun out
there that's what gets me the vibe i'm
feeling but again the acting's great
jesse buckley's great rory kinnear is
great and the body horror is cool even
though i still thought the concept of
was silly the body heart looks sick it
was you know well done so i'll give it
props for that but i do think it's one
of those movies you're either in or
you're out i'm wondering you guys think
like i just felt like once you figure
out what's going on i was like i'm not
into this man like this is not working
for me but i'm curious what everyone
thinks on this one i'm sure it's gonna
be divisive but
i mean am i crazy here because i know
there's a lot of critics who liked it
and i'm just like
this is is this like one of the worst
movies i've seen this year i think so i
mean i'm giving it a 4.9
i'm like starting to think that alex
carl is a one-trick pony here with ex
machina and that he's doing this thing
now with everything he makes doesn't
feel fully formed and thought out and
that he's constantly just
getting some interesting colorful shots
putting the creepy choir music and then
throwing in little little flashbacks
that aren't that revealing and that
aren't as smart as they should be
character-wise and connecting it well to
our main story in the main horror i just
think a lot of this was just too silly
and i think it's a swing and a miss like
you it reminds me a lot of m night
shyamalan where he has some great films
he has some
really not great films and that's alex
growing like they swing for the fences
which i appreciate i respect that i'm
happy he did that happy always does that
so props to him for that but this is a
miss to me i think he just when you do
that you know you you border with horror
like you can go
and you you take risks you try to hit a
spot that's like something we haven't
seen before crazy creative but you know
then there's the silly line you can
cross too and i feel like this movie
early on jumped into that silly line but
i mean look let me know what you thought
maybe this really worked for you if it
did i really want to hear why it did
what what sucked you in what was the
feeling why why do you think i'm wrong
if you think i'm i want to hear that and
if you agree i'd love to hear why you
didn't like it and you know maybe you're
in the middle about but again please
comment i love your thoughts on this i'm
sure it's going to be a very very
polarizing film
please follow me on st valley show on
twitter instagram and tick tock for more
of me and i'll see you next time